of going red my name is fear back
welcome back to some more
we just found out a terrible secret
found out why John I don't know if it's
true or not but apparently John said
some mean things about River and that he
only wanted to see her because I just
love her every time we see this thing
would guarantee a free memory link it
must have been left as a big scar on his
mind as it did of mine all right got the
light ball we can I go back in town and
there's something missing to the story I
don't really buy the whole thing that
comma offer wallet psyche ah what the
hell Hey
all right not cool Eva you never [ __ ]
block someone in the middle of
kamehameha what all right let's go back
in town let's take this backpack and
salsa mother f upon sound this is
complicated as [ __ ] girl
oh now I screwed
oh no God dang it
well if I did like this i whatever what
are you doing girl I mess this up bad my
bad I mean not good but not good I mean
terrible god damn it well you're living
your landlady like it's no big deal it's
no big dad don't all right let's go back
in town
so it's pretty clear now that she
actually had that spurring her I
understood that it's this weird how
parents could raise a younger sister and
give her a diagnose and then raise River
and not give her a diagnose it just
doesn't make sense to me I'm going to
school now MA have a nice day Joey he's
really young now my baby boy growing up
so fast what it what is he gonna do
Marty okay he's going to school that's
good back what if he was a girl would
she still Nick can name him after his
grandpa it wouldn't be that bad actually
since it ends with a Joey Joey Julie
sounds yeah not really if it sounds like
you why don't you marry good find that
girl
ah of course yes oh yes so jealous
all right we need to find some more
memory links oh no the clock has to be
one well to be fair a ticking clock is
pretty annoying indeed yes
and ha this entering the room gave us
one the ball
ah the ball is the momenta okay and we
should go up here maybe his mom has a
memento ha
Picard olive ah nothing yet
it's the only crap my Knights totally
blown you're easily impressed
yep you are those were not all in
pickles
no worser cucumbers it's still
disgusting and I wouldn't eat it's in
various books okay
the bar has been evacuate and lack that
flank abated is it really the ball or
the captain I'm Calvin it wait going
went back in time that was a really
short segment I don't really know what
was that for that I guess they just want
us to leave back in time faster okay
this looks pretty difficult
actually no I think I got it yep
nail that that's how I roll it that I
get are the ladies okay sorry I don't
know what that was
let's go back in Tamara's what was that
what was up with that I'm get it it's
probably gonna be more dialogue here ah
it smells like roadkill again where are
we
Eva Oh what in the hell is that
uh uh
his memories breaking down
what what is put in the half
that is his next memory yeah but why is
going a little potluck poot honest I
don't know it's just not linking the
memories together for construction there
must be a malfunction but instead
machines angry dinosaur Glu team again I
thought the last fix was foolproof
for another half a year I can't believe
those areas in the maintenance
department like don't worry we already
got in the teenage years saying we might
still be able to do this how do what all
right but I'm telling him about this as
long as we succeed he doesn't have to
know know what well I guess this is it
there's nothing we can do here ready to
finalize before activation ladies first
ah what a gentleman what a lovely
gentleman dilation gentlemen what's he
gonna do what a shame I was actually
looking borrowing to it - what - what
give me answers this game never gives
you answers and even him even when they
do they don't give you much ACTU when
was there an act 1 billions of
lighthouse suck at the far end of the
sky
ok
Oh we're going back out oh oh look
No where are we uh
don't disturb him he might not wake it's
me but they need the concentration what
Oz is real well what huh we're back here
now okay
what oh this is when we fired messed him
and this is all and that's all this sold
for now hey sorry I can't be more of
help then they'll have to be enough Hey
all that's left to do is linking your
register decided to go to the moon to
your early memories then we'll pull the
switch and voila you'll be on the moon
in no time I have a question
if you could make a lily disappear that
means you can alter this world well no
don't make anyone disappear John then
can you not simply make things happen
then fulfill my wish here and now that
would work if this were your one true
set of memory what do you mean what if
what is this then what am i what this is
just a copy a canvas for us to work with
if you will as for you you are merely an
algorithm trace from Johnny enough to
reflect his likeness but far from
complete hmm all right all we can do is
to prepare the cameras in a logical
consistent way and then when we transfer
your desire a registered aside to your
childhood the machine will generate your
new life one where the desire dictates
your behavior I don't know why you would
go back and [ __ ] up with your brain like
that's weird the result of that would
then be written to the real a John so
you see even if we satisfy you you are
merely a read-only program I mean we
could have set you over and over again
and that's enough oh don't be so
sensitive he's not really you know if
you truly believe that why did you even
care to explain that's right good point
there Rosalie I'm just trying to save
time let's go why did we go back here we
dr.
is that what I'd surely had
I guess you know I guess knows who knows
what's up and down not rainbows cold
oh these are all the member items ah all
of our nights work yeah there they are
oh there was four for each age I didn't
even realize that I didn't even realize
that we just don't have anything for the
young one oh we have holy [ __ ] we went
back in time a lot of times what is he
doing come on what day at least give me
a warning first what can I say I like
being a head come on man I'd ask that's
a pun but I'm already afraid you say yes
oh let's do this fast I feel silly
enough in this form as it is all we need
to do is to pass his desire from the
latest memory to there
okay the latest one line up to matching
mementos on the edges to transfer the
register like that okay
we just have to realize which ones are
the same because here the same are the
flower so like I like this there we go
and then the other one should be pretty
straightforward or maybe not
I'm an idiot these are not the same
maybe the bags no hey you guys check
this out oh no no no seriously okay well
which one's mad the book all right let's
see the bird okay then it's got to be
like this
now can we do this no we can't now we
can't do the bunnies match only the
fires there we go not on that baby goats
don't like I mean like name well one of
these match the clock is there a clock
yeah thought okay
it shouldn't be that difficult
oh I did it and I mean of cars I hate it
what what did I do
okay I solved it apparently thing that's
about all the ones we can work with
ready to pull the switch
oh yeah now we pull the switch that's
what they were talking about you know me
always ready let's do it let's go
alright what is happening all right
let's go check out what this Suman is we
brought back from the moon ladies first
not this time huh and the next episode
I'm sorry I've damaged we're there but
like favorite if you enjoyed takes a
second helps out a lot
the little dancer subscribe home with a
Nazi next episode okay whatever I'm a
father you'd over here out London
satellite low-oxygen don't worry I got
this here you go man